when people are looking to buy your
recruitment business they're not buying
what your business has done historically
what they're doing is they're buying
your future profits so first and
foremost they're buying you future
profits not what you've done
historically
you have to reach a certain level of
scale
from a profitability perspective where
you're going to be able to interest
enough people
to look at and be interested in buying
your business to justify a large enough
multiple which would make it probably
worthwhile for you to sell that business
so just to be a little bit more
definitive with that I would suggest to
you that unless you can reach 3 million
ebitda
your your business probably isn't going
to be worth what you think it is or what
you would like it to be from a multiple
perspective and again without going into
lots and lots of detail around that
are important for people to understand
because there's a lot of
people rate recruitment businesses but
the reality is they're just not at the
sort of scale that would
um attract a large enough number of
buyers to be interested who would then
create the competition amongst
themselves to be able to drive up the
multiple to sell that business a
valuation which you probably think your
business is worth and I would suggest
your starting point is about three
million the recruitment mentors podcast
is proudly sponsored by VIN cherry and
the award-winning Source breaker